foreign
I want to talk a little bit about an
um an interview or a discussion that
took place on Barry Weiss's podcast
honestly with a woman named Helen Lewis
and
the problem is that that the two of them
uh
specifically take me to task and we will
come back to the meaning of that but I'm
not interested in talking about this
because they take me to task though it
does mean that I am expert on some of
the things they say and am in a position
to comment on the veracity or lack
thereof of those things Barry had Alan
Lewis on her podcast earlier I think it
was last Friday B and Michael
schellenberger and Renee doresta were on
Sam Harris's podcast and Barry says
something in both cases almost
identically
which I believe is a reference you know
so in some sense in in Barry's own
podcast she tries to uninvent the IDW
and she basically imagines it as her
creation you know maybe she made her
article created something that didn't
really exist wasn't wasn't for real in
the first place which is kind of a
nonsense uh idea but in talking about
the IDW She lays out a trajectory where
she says you know I think people
who you know got something right and
noticed that something wasn't being well
stated by the official institutions then
fell down the rabbit hole and they went
from you know the CDC was wrong on masks
or whatever her example is uh to another
example is that Bill Gates is trying to
inject you with a microchip uh in your
brain because of the great reset
this angered me to hear it because a I
think prototypical straw man it's a
prototypical straw man because it starts
out right and in fact it doesn't even
end entirely wrong is the great reset a
problem yeah I think it probably is is
Bill Gates involved yeah I don't exactly
understand why but
you know there's something there does
this have anything to do with microchips
in the brain no that was you throwing
something in there to toxify the well so
that nobody would start to try to sort
out what the relationship of these
things is so anyway
um
what I want to do most such Maneuvers
are unwitting
I'm not saying that that one was but um
take pieces that might be plausible and
add to them pieces that sound so absurd
that by tying them together you make you
you you you cause people who haven't yet
started to investigate such a thing be
like oh there's too many things to do in
the world about that one not that one
that's toxic well
I don't know if it's witting or
unwitting but this definitely feels
strategic which I do not
um I do not begrudge Barry
uh
a strategic nature obviously strategy is
important in order to get good things
accomplished but what she's
accomplishing in this case
um I don't believe is legitimate and the
there are several features here that
tell me something is off
so Barry and Helen are having this
discussion and they're talking about
what the IDW is and Barry describes the
IDW
um and she basically names a number of
the male participants who were in her
article
and says then there were some females as
well you are again disappeared and that
will become relevant when we get to the
part where I come in for critique I
think your disappearance has a meaning
this is not the first time we've seen it
Sam does it and Barry is now doing it
but let me let me I mean I think there's
one of three three things going on there
well let me put my hypothesis on the
table you tell me if it's in your list
the podcast that Barry does where I'm
claiming that she's involved in this
Middle Ground scramble to create an
explanation for how she and others
missed the boat on covid and uh slap
power on the wrist in a way that it will
want
um
is traffics in the uh moniker gurus
right Helen has taken up the idea of
gurus in earnest
and I am effectively portrayed as one
I think
look the fact is during covid as you and
I were doing what we did
we played different roles you know I've
always been
um more
theoretical in
my work so the roles are asymmetrical
but
there was no asymmetry in the level of
contribution in fact one of the things
that comes up in the little clip that
I'm going to play is a contribution that
you made the response to something Helen
says is something that I got from you so
my point would be
if you're gonna I don't know what we're
talking about if you're gonna level the
allegation
that um
podcast listeners are falling for gurus
right the point is well you and I don't
look like a guru because a guru doesn't
tend to look like two scientific people
having a conversation about hypotheses
predictions and tests right that's not a
guru move that's a science move yeah
right after two people to use a singular
pronoun that's just tricky right so
indeed in fact I can't even figure out
how you do it but um but the point is if
they are going to dismiss us as not
having been right because what we really
did and you know Barry's language is you
know when she says you go from spotting
that the CDC screwed up uh masks to
thinking Bill Gates is trying to inject
you with microchips if he describes it
as falling down the rabbit hole Yeah
doesn't sound good it's funny though a
lot of the heterodox thinkers who are
quite good use the metaphor rabbit hole
for themselves right the point is this
is not inherently a bad thing and in
fact a rabbit hole isn't a rabbit hole a
rabbit hole is a rabbit Warren and so in
going down a rabbit hole built into the
metaphor is the idea that there will be
blind alleys right going down the rabbit
hole is about sorting what is that also
unexpected ways out yeah multiple
multiple ways in right so anyway
um maybe we should play the clip and
then we can talk about what it's
implicated it's short
um
so yeah exactly yeah we are ready
give them so much to kick against and
the more that people said you know these
people are awful you shouldn't listen to
them you shouldn't see them you
shouldn't rather than rebutting them
either more power they got right and I
felt very strongly when I went into that
Jordan Peterson interview I this is the
one but I do remember having a
conversation with myself about I will
never say in that interview I'm never
going to say anything that you say is
offensive I'm going to say well if I
think it's wrong and I'm going to make
the argument about why it's wrong and I
think that's the thing is that there was
the overused cudgel of a fence and
blasphemy rather than as you say you can
say to Brett Weinstein well look there's
very good evidence that the vaccines are
safe and effective and that Ivermectin
was a promising treatment at one point
but we now have a good meta-analysis
review that says sorry no it's not and
it's not a big Pharma conspiracy because
it's a generic drug that's very cheap
like you know this isn't like it would
have been you know lots of things that
were you know like basic steroids
dexamethasone for example was in exactly
the same position I've ever met him was
but that one turned out to work and so
people prescribed that one like what's
your mechanism where he's why you think
this was suppressed and that's the
argument that you should be making right
rather than you must not question the
wisdom of the elders you have
to partake
okay
um
so
Helen in this clip is portraying me as
somebody who can't grok even basic
information about covet and she says you
know you can tell Brett Weinstein that
there is you know evidence that the
vaccines are safe and effective the
implication being I simply am unaware of
that evidence or worse that the evidence
exists
and that I refuse to accept it for some
reason
now the fact is there is an awful lot of
evidence there is mounting evidence that
the vaccines are unsafe it does not mean
that nobody gets away with being
injected presumably most people do but
the idea that she is simply going to
slip in there the assumption that the
evidence tells us that these things are
safe and effective is preposterous now I
will point out Barry says nothing Barry
a journalist who knows that there is
mounting evidence of the hazard of these
vaccines has an obligation
journalistically to challenge that it is
not simply true that they are safe and
effective and I believe that Barry
actually has in her Circle somebody
who's been vaccine injured so she knows
better and she had an obligation to say
so what's more she's talking about the
IDW
and there are a number of people in the
IDW or close to it who also know of
vaccine injuries so you know there's a
vaccine injured person uh in that realm
there's somebody with a spouse the fact
is this is not a realm in which a
journalist can bypass the fact that
there is evidence around us of something
more than safe and effective but then
worse she goes on
to say that um you know another thing
that you can't seem to convey to me
because apparently I'm too dumb to get
it is that Ivermectin seemed promising
but then she says but we now have a
compelling meta-analysis that tells us
that that is not the case really
I think Helen Lewis does not understand
what the state of the evidence is on
Ivermectin I think she's barely familiar
with it and that her use of the term
meta-analysis tells us that I think
she's not referring to a meta-analysis
because if she is she's either referring
to the Cochrane meta-analysis which said
Ivermectin didn't work the Cochrane
meta-analysis which is compromised by
the fact that they set inclusion
criteria for which studies would be uh
represented and then violated their own
criteria and if she's not talking about
that one she's talking about the Andy
Hill meta-analysis
the Andy Hill meta-analysis with Andy
Hill on videotape captured by Tess
Laurie admits he changed the conclusion
based on his funder's preference right
so he's certainly not talking about the
Lorry analysis meta-analysis because
that one shows up in the opposite
direction right so a what she's done is
just if she's talking about the
meta-analyzes she's either
misrepresenting them or uh remaining
ignorant of the actual underlying
problem with these things or she doesn't
mean meta-analysis all and she's
throwing that in there to sound
technical well and I think and then
she's referring to for example the
together trial or the active six trial
where we also have evidence of fraud
where for example the dosing carries
this unexplained parameter where people
above a certain BMI have their dose
capped and when you have a disease that
afflicts people in proportion to the
degree of their obesity and you you
start under dosing people the fatter
they are of course you cause a problem
so the fact is she is representing this
as Brett Weinstein simply cannot
understand the state of the evidence
that I ever met in when in fact she
doesn't apparently understand the state
of the evidence herself well well and so
I don't I I'm not that interested in
talking about
um why I'm not present in many of these
uh in many of these attempted takedowns
of you but I said that I think that
there's three different reasons and I do
think that those three different reasons
are useful to consider across the board
with regard to this but just let's
remember
that the the reason this is important is
that this cannot happen again and that
this Middle Ground scramble as you have
described it in which the institutions
that are flawed and failing are trying
to keep some of their imprimature of
seriousness and are effectively signing
on with or the other pseudo-heterodox
sort of Talking Heads or signing on with
the idea of what the institutions have
always been doing without understanding
anything about what has actually
happened and so you're just gonna get
it's like the the metaphor that I was
thinking of was like it's it's like
rearranging deck chairs on the analysis
except for rearranging intellectuals
like it's just like you've got you're
gonna replace some of the old Talking
Heads with some new Talking Heads and
they seemed heterodox at some point but
it turns out they're not courageous
these are not the courageous people
they're just following along like
everyone else looking for power and no
not everything is about power but these
moves are so
um you know why why don't I show up when
Sam Harris talks and Scott Adams and you
know and Helen Lewis and Barry Weiss and
such I think it's one of three reasons
and it's some combination often
one because people aren't actually
paying attention they've never heard you
and me talk they've they never heard you
talk
um they haven't actually engaged the
material they've gotten their
information from someone else and that I
suspect not knowing very much at all
about the situation is what for instance
Helen has done she has she's never heard
anything here and you know but it's also
true that you know you went on with
Robert Malone and Steve Kersh you went
out with Pierre Corey like you do the
the guest hosting and so you know you're
more out there you're easier for the
people who want to hate on you know what
it is that we're doing and what you're
doing to grab you and to take it and so
I think one of the big reasons is
um it's a reveal of actually I never
actually listened to or read anything
that here they said and so I'm gonna
just focus there that's one
second reason is that in some cases
um not this particular these these two
women presumably although I don't know
is that it's actual cryptic misogyny and
that they're accustomed to not paying
attention to women being influential in
a space
um that sounds you know that sounds like
things that they can't understand and
therefore probably this is not a thing
that women would do uh well so that's
obnoxious and terrible if it's true and
yeah but I do think that that is um that
is part of the reason sometimes and the
third reason
uh I think that this happens and I do
think that this is part of what's going
on with the um podcast you're talking
about now is that it's strategic and
it's more difficult to take down the two
of us together because as you say uh we
don't look like a guru right we look
like two people with scientific
backgrounds and yes also credentials but
that's not the thing that matters here
we have decades both individually and
even more decades between us thinking
carefully through scientific
patterns and processes making
observations in the world figuring out
what hypotheses might explain them how
to test between how to discriminate
between those hypotheses and how to move
forward that is what we do
professionally both of us and yes I'm
more of an empiricist back when we were
actually practicing scientists in the
way that most people think of when they
think of it and you were more of a
theorist but you know I do Theory you do
empiricism like we we both do both
things and it's just far easier to have
it be especially in this era this like
this even the people who claim to be the
most anti-work like oh let's go after
the dude he's you know it's just it's
this guy who's just off off the cuff
he's just not making any sense you just
can't talk to him you can't talk to him
about Ivermectin really like I'm I'm
guessing that this is what you were
talking about when you said that one of
the things that they talk about is
something that I brought I haven't
gotten there yet okay well like I
remember
I remember having gotten up one early
one Saturday back
almost two years ago probably maybe two
years ago and we were still living in
Portland and I don't remember how I went
there but I went down that rabbit Warren
have Ivermectin and emergency use
authorizations and you came downstairs
and I looked at you my jaw dropped it's
like
I think I have stumbled upon the most
egregious example yet of anything in the
pandemic to date that that I or we have
talked about and it was Ivermectin
so that's the piece yeah um it is
specifically the emergency use
authorization because the last thing
that Helen says in the clip that we
played is that it doesn't even make
sense that there would be uh some sort
of collusion to exclude Ivermectin as a
treatment for covid because it's a
generic drug and it's cheap okay Alan
that's a non-sequitur right the reason
that people imagine that Ivermectin was
blocked was because it was a direct
competitor to these vaccines which were
emergency use authorized and emergency
use authorization requires that they're
not be a viable treatment in order to be
granted yeah they're being a direct
component
people have not heard that they're being
a direct competitor to the vaccine to to
the vaccines to prevent coven precludes
the eua and therefore would have
precluded uh the vaccines going on the
market when they did right and then she
says that um this her point is proven
because uh she names a
um
something uh
going to skip it for the second but the
point is the fact that some other
generic drug is being used and yes it is
used for pulmonary uh compromise that
comes along with covid is it
dextromethorphan no no no no no
um anyway the No No the fact that she
uses the fact that she uses this example
is uh evidence that she doesn't
understand what's going on because the
point is
Ivermectin has two values it does treat
people with covid effectively assuming
you treat them early with a sufficient
dose
this has been demonstrated many times
and we can talk about why you think the
evidence says that it doesn't but that
evidence is not persuasive but the other
thing it does is it is a preventative of
Contracting covet and so the point is
these you're comparing uh apples to
spaceships that they're not comparable
and
um
you know
I'm now thrown by Zach who says that we
didn't play as much of the clip as our
as I uh thought that we played but
nonetheless there's like four or five
sentences involved in her critique and
there's three or four critical errors in
what she says now my point is going to
be he's not actually trying to make an
analytical point she's trying to sound
like she's making an analytical point
the actual payload of this entire
exploration
is the word guru
the idea is
this is not going to compel anybody who
actually pays attention to the podcast
what this is going to do is prevent
other people from paying attention
that's its purpose is to stigmatize us
to make us sound like and and this is a
move that we see repeatedly now the idea
is if that thing persuades you that's
because you're a sucker and so the point
is anybody who hears us and thinks oh
well that's not what I thought it was
that actually sounds kind of compelling
that sounds like a scientific discussion
that sounds like a discussion I'd like
to pay attention to ah you're a sucker
you're falling for a guru it's you know
something is fitting a religion-shaped
hole in your persona and that's why
you're responding to it so this is
designed it's like you know
it's like skunk stink it's supposed to
make it difficult for people to get
anywhere near this discussion because
really the point is another discussion
has to take place and it's not up to the
challenge
yeah well I will I will repeat that um I
mean also not on my list of people we've
been hearing from who are um grateful
for the conversations in which we um try
to logic through evidence out loud in
front of the camera uh our uh many
Tradesmen right we got roofers and and
you know all all sorts of people who are
again doing physical things in the world
uh
I would hope
that anyone who is so convinced that
what uh we're doing is based on a simple
rubric of contrarianism
or
um falling prey to some kind of
something something something
uh I I would propose first that you know
that's you're recognizing a part of your
own brain and that part is not
necessarily Universal
and that if you get yourself in the
habit of doing something physical in the
world
and seeing the manifestations of it then
you will be more able in the future to
distinguish between arguments that are
careful and logical and arguments which
are entirely based in Social conclusions
and I think most of what we're hearing
um most of what you're talking about
here are arguments based entirely in the
social sphere with sort of nodding
passing
referral to uh sciency things but this
is coming from people who aren't
actually engaging any of the evidence
yeah
um that's quite right
I would say that they've there are
multiple ways that they are attempting
to dismiss the conversation that now
needs to take place and people should be
um aware of all of them right you've
mentioned contrarianism right to the
extent that the system got really
essentially everything wrong about covid
from its origin to the best mechanism
for treating it to the safety of the
vaccines all of these things the utility
of vitamin D all of these things that
got wrong and so if the system is in the
practice of getting everything wrong yes
a contrarian could get there without
understanding anything but that doesn't
make people who understood contrarians
by Nature yeah I don't know and I and I
think we talked about this last week but
I wrote I wrote a piece in my subset
last year that
I have been just been sending to people
when they you know like oh you're just a
contrarian like no that is the opposite
of science it is the opposite of science
is the opposite of science so is Faith
both of those things simply having an
idea in advance of I will or I will I
will accept or I will reject whatever
the authority says that's not scientific
um in addition
I also uh hear especially from uh from
various quadrants including
um
oh boy
damn
I've forgotten
um
the
thing that Barry says in this podcast is
that and actually Helen picks up on this
and runs with it the idea is that all of
this is explainable by audience capture
right a term that Helen correctly
attributes to Eric and then missed
defines Right audience capture would be
the idea that you simply start saying
the things that the audience wants to
hear because it's lucrative right and I
want to point out that yes that's a very
sophisticated sounding uh rationale for
dismissing a correct line of logic but
what is really obvious and should be
obvious to anybody who pays attention to
this podcast is that we are very
frequently
arriving at a position for which there
is exactly no audience right like for
example
um global warming is real it's dangerous
but the models are crap and the fields
that study this are going to be
compromised by the same perverse
incentives that compromise covet policy
the vaccines are obviously a hazard
so is covet right the obvious thing if
you were going to follow some uh path to
some audience that wanted to hear
something is to follow it to some
audience that actually exists like
covet's not serious and the vaccines are
dangerous
um right but the point is time and time
again I remember being asked by a
conservative friend
maybe a year into the pandemic
why is it that you're skeptical of
vaccines and yet you think covet is a
real problem
and I mean that was really the phrasing
and I'm not going to say who it was and
I thought what do those two things have
to do with one another those are two
different that those are those are
really unrelated and if you are coming
to your conclusions because of who your
team has voted for yeah you're not doing
science
so you know let's put it this way you
can just simply look at the various ways
that um
and I don't I wish this weren't personal
I wish we were talking about somebody
else's podcast because it would be a lot
easier uh to do this but you can't get
to where we are by contrarianism by
reflexive contrarianism because the
point is the place that we have arrived
is not otherwise on the map right
um You can't get there through luck
because the track record is too many uh
things that were unlikely but turned out
um to be true and you can't get there by
uh falling down a rabbit hole either
because the point is the pattern would
Peter out
so none of these things
um make sense it's not a coin flip it's
a scientific process it is uh it
shouldn't be true that it is possible to
do this on a podcast and
um you know come up with a superior
model to whatever the CDC is playing
with but it is apparently possible and
that really is the discussion we should
be having it has nothing to do with
gurus
and
um you know it's really uh
it's quite disgusting for people who
have not gotten coveted right to be
challenging those who have gotten it
right over time through a process which
we have done in public so that other
people will not pay attention right that
is just it's an unacceptable thing to do
and frankly the amount of hutzpah
involved in doing such a thing is pretty
remarkable I must say I'm a bit
horrified to be hearing this from both
Sam uh and Barry both of them know
better and
um I really I hope they find their way
back to sanity
[Music]
thank you